>> WHAT'S IT LIKE TO BE THE
FIRST OVERALL PICK IN THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE DRAFT?
OWEN POWER KNOWS BECAUSE IT JUST
HAPPENED TO HIM TONIGHT IN
ONTARIO AS HE CELEBRATES WITH
HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
ADVISORS.
JACKIE REDMON CAUGHT UP WITH THE
FIRST PICK OF THE DRAFT.
JACKIE: OWEN, CONGRATULATIONS, A
DREAM REALIZED, SOMETHING I'M
SURE YOU IMAGINED A MILLION
TIMES OVER IN YOUR LIFETIME.
YOU'VE GOT YOUR WHOLE FAMILY
THERE.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THIS
MOMENT IN YOUR YOUNGER SELF?
OWEN: I MEAN, IT'S PRETTY
SPECIAL.
IT'S SOMETHING I DREAMED ABOUT
MY WHOLE LIFE.
I DON'T KNOW IF MY YOUNGER SELF
WOULD HAVE REALLY BELIEVED IT SO
--
JACKIE: WELL, BELIEVE IT.
IT'S REAL.
YOU'RE OFFICIALLY A MEMBER OF
THE BUFFALO SABRES.
YOU HAVE A DECISION AHEAD OF YOU
TO PLAY FOR THE SABRES THIS
COMING SEASON OR TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
YOU'VE SAID BEFORE, YOU'RE
LEANING TOWARDS SCHOOL.
HOW DO YOU FEEL IN THIS MOMENT
ABOUT THAT CHOICE?
OWEN: YEAH, I MEAN, I'M NOT
THINKING ABOUT IT TOO MUCH.
I'M JUST TRYING TO ENJOY THE
NIGHT.
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING I'LL
WORRY ABOUT LATER.
JACKIE: YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE CELEBRATING WITH YOU.
I'M SURE IT WILL BE QUITE A
PARTY.
THE SABRES FAN, ONE OF THE MOST
PASSIONATE FANS IN HOCKEY.
THEY WILL EXCITED TO DON THEIR
SWEATER.
>> YEAH, I'M JUST SUPER EXCITED
TO BE A PART OF THE FRANCHISE
AND READY TO GET GOING.
JACKIE: ALL RIGHT.